William bny who for over 30 years worked
with the US National Security Agency a
former cryptographer and later a
whistleblower Benny was the nsa's
technical leader of intelligence Benny
has a high level understanding of the
agency's data collection systems what
that means is any iPhone or any phone in
the world first connecting to the
network when you want to use it you're
immediately known worldwide I mean all
the switches have you and they capture
your IPS all that in your phone and Mac
numbers and all that that's how they
bill you so that also is the known by
the network and the implants computer
network exploitation implants they have
around the world over this was in 2004
or 2010 somewhere in that range they had
over 50,000 implants in all these switch
servers and networks worldwide I mean
that means they own the entire network
so that if you your phone comes on the
air then they can they can know who you
are and where you are